[Music]
the new york jets have cab space and
they are using it trading for kolechi
osemily that will be official on
wednesday right after 4 p.m
signing some players to the offensive
side of the ball led by former
washington wideout jameson crowder three
years 28.5 million but the two big moves
one came last night one came this
morning former vikings linebacker
anthony barr on monday night now early
tuesday
former ravens linebacker cj mosley five
years 85 million with 51 million
guaranteed 17 million a year from mosley
who wanted to stay with the ravens but
the jets came in with the big money
chris
is this going to make a difference for
the jets or do they have more work that
they need to do more holes that they
need to fill well no i mean i certainly
think it's a good start i mean the jets
hey uh they're in prime position to get
a pass rusher in the draft which they
need dearly as well so it seems like
that's setting up more and more for that
but the jets hey secondary play is not
bad you got jamal adams who i would
argue is the best safety in football now
you get guys like cj mosley and anthony
barr who never have to come off the
field yeah they can play and do all the
traditional things you want out of
linebackers as far as stopping the run
but these are three down linebackers and
when i say three down linebackers i mean
these are guys that stay on the field in
passing situations because they're smart
they're extremely athletic they're long
so they have a big radius it's not easy
to throw over them or around them i
really like both of those signings they
automatically are in the conversation
right away for one of the best duos at
linebacker in football and and mike
kolechi i keep messing his name
he is he's still got some good years
left on him he is one of the better
guards in football yeah he's maybe just
our starting on the down slope of his
career and jamison crowder you want to
talk about helping out sam darnold it's
a sneaky good receiver receiver and
group they have with the jets they have
good tight ends and jameson crowder for
my money mike is one of the better slot
receivers in all of football so the jets
are kicking butt right now spending the
money i think very wisely
you said something about not being able
to throw over around anthony barr and i
mentioned this earlier in the hour and i
didn't give you a chance to push back
the way you'd like to but yes i have a
vivid memory of a thursday night game
between the vikings and the rams it was
a close game 38-31 but three touchdowns
were scored because anthony barr tried
to cover first cooper cup then robert
woods then todd gurley i may have the
order of those last two off but three
different times he got burned for
touchdowns i believe all three were
touchdowns yeah and i know that coaching
is a big part of this but just don't put
anthony barr in space and expect him to
cover somebody who's running a pass run
yeah let's not put him in space and
expect them to cover like you know oh
wide receivers who are not even the same
animal he is and i mean that as far as
football animals i mean anthony barr
should be covering tight ends down the
field maybe the back out of the
backfield a few times a game when he's
got a cover on man-to-man but you're
just a bitter minnesota fan don't blame
anthony barr for some of those issues
you saw in that thursday night game you
need to talk to your buddy mike zimmer
on that one because he he is the one
that got anthony barr in bad spots in
positions where he was set up to fail i
mean there's no way he should be
covering anthony bart or a cooper cup 20
30 yards down the field that was a one
of our first clues of wow the minnesota
defense uh the the they cracked the code
sean mcveigh and boy genius so you know
that that's not his fault he is still
one of the better
wait he's boy blunder now remember
now you can't call him he was a boy
genius then he was kid genius then but
yes now he's boy blunder but anthony
barr is very good at pass coverage so
don't let those three plays uh you know
make or make anthony barr seem any less
than what he is
it's so funny though how
people in the in the media get caught up
in narratives that aren't necessarily
accurate like i saw yesterday when the
news broke a bar going to the jets oh
the jets pick up a pass rusher he's got
13 and a half sacks in five seasons no
thanks
if you're signing the gotta be a pass
rusher i think you have better options
out there all due respect yes they do
and yeah anthony barr played defense at
end at ucla but they moved him to stand
up linebacker and he has played that
position really well hey there's just
not a lot of guys on planet earth okay
that are 6'4 255 and can run like
anthony barkin and can turn his hips and
pass coverage and do all of those things
so that's where he's special i mean greg
williams must be absolutely ecstatic for
what they got but yeah they're not
getting them to rush the passer but when
you talk about the two linebackers okay
you talk about some of the guys they got
in the secondary lake we did early in
the segment leonard williams at
defensive tackle they got the number
three pick in the draft which is set up
for nick bosa josh allen top tier pass
rushers coming off the edge the jets
could be a completely different defense
uh once otas or at least the start of
the preseason comes around
here's the last thing i'll say about
anthony barr
the vikings over the past seven or eight
years have identified their core young
talent and they have signed them to
long-term deals and barr is the only guy
that i can think of that they didn't do
that with and this gets back to that
debate where yeah
the team that knows a guy better than
anyone it's five years with anthony barr
they're not willing to pay what a
stranger to borrow is willing to pay him
and somebody's getting this wrong chris
i get you and we're gonna find out who
it is well we don't know how much
they're paying him uh first of all but
we'll see with that but yeah more than
what the vikings would pay well that's
right well the vikings too you got to
get you got to talk about they have a
lot of people they're paying a whole lot
of money to i mean the other middle line
oh i'm aware yeah oh that's very aware
of that 29 million dollars this year in
cap space
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports